you're going to hear me start telling
the story and you're going to think uh
David you did the story you did the
story before you're doing the same story
again well I've done similar stories
many times this year because it happened
many times NASA through data collected
by the Goddard Institute for Space
Studies has just announced that
September of 2016 last month was the
hottest on record this means that 11 of
the last 12 months have been the hottest
ever on record Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump they both say I am going to
be the next leader of the free world
have spent under two minutes discussing
the issue of climate change in the first
two presidential debates September 2016
was the warmest September in 136 years
of modern record keeping now the deniers
will say wait wait wait a second David a
hundred and thirty-six years that
represents nothing in terms of the
history of the the earth and our
universe we can't deduce anything broad
about a planet that has been around for
4.5 billion years from a hundred and
thirty-six year trend and you know what
you would be right in one way but also
very very wrong it is true right that
temperatures alone in the last hundred
and thirty-six years don't tell us what
we need to know to determine whether or
not or to what degree humans are
impacting climate on the planet overall
we might be seeing cyclical warming and
what we would need to determine is are
we seeing non-cyclical warming and 136
years of data isn't going to tell us
that but there are many other types of
data which the climate deniers usually
will pretend doesn't exist when they say
136 years give me a break it tells us
nothing for example if we look at an
analysis of ice cores and sediments
these suggests that the warming of
recent decades is completely out of step
with any period over the past millennium
some people will argue we're still sort
of coming out of an ice age so that
warming makes sense well we have data
comparing past ice age
exits I guess I'll call them to this one
and we are crushing those numbers
temperature reconstructions done by NASA
using work from NOAA the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
found that the global temperature
typically rose for 27 degrees Celsius
over a period of five thousand years is
the world would normally exit an ice age
the temperature rise clocked above uh
clocked over the past century is around
10 times faster than the previous rate
of warming in similar geological times
and the increasing pace of warming's of
both of the warming that we're seeing
means that the world is going to be
heating up at a rate that is quote at
least 20 times faster than the
historical average over the next hundred
years according to NASA lastly for
people who say we only have data from a
hundred years we don't know what's going
on scientists are able to gauge gene
greenhouse gas levels stretching back
more than 800,000 years but the
certainty around the composition of
previous climates is stronger within the
past thousand years so when the deniers
tell you a hundred and thirty-six years
of surface temperature data really don't
tell us anything you can talk about the
ice cores you can talk about greenhouse
gas levels stretching back 800,000 years
we have the data be equipped with the
fact this is a major major deal and to
the extent that now we can track daily
surface temperature monthly surface
temperature etc we'll use that as part
of the biggest big picture of data that
we have about this don't let the deniers
trick you because that's all that they
want to do